all right minister seymour
yes sir mr seymour where are you from
originally where'd you grow up from
chicago
and you're still based there yes sir
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
uh yes i had when i was a kid my mother
died when i was a little boy i was about
seven
eight years old i'm sorry and how would
you describe your childhood
well it was roughs coming up coming up
um
the babysitters used to keep me and my
brothers as you know for
fine out daddy used to go to work with
what would your dad do for work daddy
was a minister
at his own church so sometime that
the babysitter's come over you know and
tricked me and my brother's in the bed
with her
so what what could we do so your your
sexual activity start at what age
well about seven to ten you know
you know the babysitters you know the
women's they want to play with the
little boys you know
when the little boys go through things
in life so it's changed their life too
you know how far did you go in school i
finished school
with two years of college yeah yeah
did you have dreams of doing something
in life that uh well i did i had dreams
of doing a lot of things when you was uh
disturbed you you know my like i said my
mother she passed when i was a little
boy you know i did finish school
but i was something like the preacher
kids in the neighborhood stayed in
trouble all the times you know broken
the telephones took all the dimes out
the telephones and nickels
you know and uh um back then you know uh
i'm in my 60s now so you know we talking
about years ago
it would just cost uh 15
to make a phone call so 10 cent
so they made a phone call you said i
used to bust all the
telephones and take all the cash out the
uh telephone machines and take it home
to me and my brothers and
feed me and my brothers you know and how
did you get introduced to the
world of well you know uh
i wound up going to school too i
supposed to be doing my homework on it
i wound up at my english teacher house
you know so hey man i had to do what i
had to do to survive
you know to put food on the table you
know which i came from a good
family but they say the preacher kids
were some of the baddest kids in the
neighborhood and i was
i was one of them did you have someone
to show you the ropes or you just
figured it out
i had some great uncles you know on one
name uh
richard tidwell was the greatest player
he was a boss player gambler dress lock
i used to watch him and stay sharp all
the time he used to wear hats
that's why i got my hats and my dressing
from one of my mother's brothers his
name was
they called him peanut titware
so here's one of your role models one of
them and i had an uncle
named george beard he was one of my
mentors too you know and uh on my
daddy's side my daddy brother he was a
great player
you know and i always watched them too
coming up and they was
good dressers and had some of the
fanciest cars i watched them with my
cars and my clothes and you know i got a
lot of knowledge from my family
the you know your sense of style the way
you dress
your your attitude that's a big part of
you know i got it from
one of my uncles like i said his name
was uh
peanut we call him peanut but floyd
tittwell was his name
but the that that ability to attract a
female is a big part of
oh well we'll factor females is just
like
what track you become that way if you
see a woman child
looking good and real clean looking
beautiful
when they see the same thing in a man if
he looking good dressed
got his nice hat on his shoes shine a
nice suit on the necktie
they love that you know and that opens
the door for opportunities to
well it'll open up a lot of things for
you just not no door it'll give you a
place to lay your head
it feeds you you know do a lot of things
for you
keep money in your pocket have you been
married
man i'm married now i've been with my
wife 45 years
45 years and living in one of the
biggest prettier houses
i got business construction business
beauty shops barbershop a fur company
i customize cars i'm doing great for
myself
that's how i did things in life when i
when i made money
i put it to the side i never drinked i
never got high
i never smoked in my life my friends did
all that i just didn't choose that life
and tell me about some of the girls that
have worked for you how many
well it's not only the girls work for
you it wasn't that it was just man i
always been a superstar
in my game always been a superstar and i
know pym people look at you because you
dress and when they see you with a big
hat on use a pimp
no i'm a always been a great superstar
if somebody wanted the chicken want to
give me some cash i'm going to accept it
you know
so a lot of times you you get with the
fast girls they don't want to go to bed
a lot of times
guys look at them they be pretty they
want
some knowledge they disturb they've been
abused they've been raped
since they was babies so they need
somebody
to encourage them and keep them tell
them what to do to get on the right road
so that's when you gain your points
by putting it in their head and telling
them
what they need to hear hey man being a
friend is some of the best
things you can come up with being a
woman friend instead of being a man
laying down with a
man i played had to dick on a lot of
chicks i didn't have to do all that
like i said i've been a superstar
and i got paid for what i knew and i
shared the game with them
and you're giving them guidance as well
so much guidance that's what i did
they paid for knowledge a lot of guys
said no no you ain't got
whatever these guys want to do that's on
them like i said i've been a great
superstar all my life
i've been a boss player i dress i look
good wherever i went
have you done any prison time um
just a little bit about four five months
or something like that
and the girls that you would uh that
that would help you the unique guy
i i'm a type of dude when i was coming
up it ain't girls girls
i may have had one or two chicks
in my game have had problems came to me
for
a name to be behind them because a lot
of guys come on them strolls and come on
the sets
jump on them and beat up they can use my
name
or use the next boss player name
and want some some uh somebody to stand
with them cause they checking all this
money
but if they can use your name they can
share that money with you man
and you're married but would you have
sex with the girls no i had to i played
half the dick
i didn't have to do that the little head
didn't make a fool out of the big head
i never did that see the little head can
make a fool out of the big head i never
had to do that
a lot of dudes did it i guess i didn't
have to do that right
how do you handle your girls if they got
out of line if they got a little
headstrong
well i'm telling you it ain't the girls
is when a person come to me if a girl
come to me needs some acknowledgements
and encouragements
i'm gonna give to them straight off the
top they can talk to where they want to
talk to be with whoever they want to be
with
hey man i've always been a superstar i'm
your friend i can be your friend wanting
to be your man
to give them freedom hey man they came
in free they can go as freedom
you respect people to give respect you
got to give it you got to be a gentleman
out here man
i feel sorry for a lot of brothers you
know where they mess with the unaged
girls and get in a world of trouble
hey man i just don't live like that man
like i said i had to
play my game way different than a lot of
brothers did man
you know i've always been alone i'll
ride by myself
i hang by myself i don't need all that
you don't do you don't need nobody to
help you count your money
you need somebody to go with you to put
it in the bank no you need your money by
yourself
so the laws have changed in this game
quite a bit oh man super
super game it's it's become much more
dangerous right
well has been dangerous all the time
girls i've got these
dope slow mints i've got these those
sliced too sitting in the car dating the
chips i'm not talking about this
danger in the street i'm talking to
danger at the police and the it's thing
it's it never changed it just didn't got
took it to another level but that
myrtle have been going on for beginning
of time
it's just sharpening it up a little bit
that's all cause the young generation
don't know what to do
they do what they want to do what is it
about the street life that makes it so
addictive to so many people man the
drugs
the drugs and took over that's the pimp
if you want to know the pimp
that's the pimp the drugs at the pimp
i'm going to tell you something
[ __ ] be thinking god i think because
he is a pimp because he got a suit on
now
the chick looking for somebody to
encourage them they
they don't know how to master their
money so you just dare to help them
to master their money a chick don't need
you what she needs you for
to fool you to make you think that you
this or that no
hey man i always stayed on the line like
i said i always been a superstar
if a chick wanted to give me some money
i'm going to accept the money because
i'm getting them all my game
all my knowledge telling them
what to do and what not to do what
personality traits do you
look for in a girl what personality
traits do you look for
in a girl man
it don't make a difference you know uh
it's kind of hard you know uh
it's it's it's really hard but it don't
make a difference bro
you can work with whoever man it's like
you go on the grocery store
if somebody you can encourage you'll
work with them
you'll talk to them that's all you there
for the money you're not there for the
honey
i'm there for the money i don't want the
honey i want the money
what's more important to you love her
money
i'd rather be loved love come first
i love i love to love somebody that who
wants to be loved
and you got to understand that you know
i love the money i ain't going to be
crazy and said
money but hey man everybody want to be
loved
how many years you've been doing this
long time man i've been doing it all my
life
since i've been in the street riding
slick looking slick
you know have my hand out for some bread
i'm sure you've seen some crazy stuff
man i've seen a lot of crazy things but
some things is not to be
told talked about insane sometimes you
got to be quiet
and what are your thoughts on how the
game has changed
well the way i dress now you got new
generation guys coming around now
nowhere in the world was some blue jeans
would have put a belt not no better than
wearing my pants down
hey man my granddaddy was a dressing man
he dressed
he wore he wore hats and oh overalls
and he never wore pants with no belt
he's playing man i couldn't even walk in
the house around none of my people my
granddaddy grandma
with my pants down you couldn't have
didn't either
that's what changed things who gonna
show they behind
i look you walking i come to your house
and i got my drawers down showing your
wife my butt
that's disrespectful and it's
disrespectful for you inviting me over
to your house
and telling you your girl i'm your
friend he got his shoe in his behind
dressing the way you do right man today
but with respect
man through the week i i wear a lot of
work clothes
i dress down i i clean up i sweep i
paint
i have to go behind the the the guys
that
working for me i'm working on cars i
love to work on cars i got to trade man
i learned to work on cars i learned to
do something positive
i know a lot of brothers don't know how
to do nothing i got a friend now
don't even know how to change the tie if
he catch a flat
all he knows just put gas in the car how
many cars you got
man i have a lot of cars i saw you
pulled up in here yeah i got a lot of
cars
where the players ball here in atlanta
well i must be here just only we've been
doing these playoffs by over 40 some
years
i must support my friend on his birthday
because he they just gave me a big party
my wife my sons
they just gave me a big party in chicago
i mean you couldn't even get in
and uh my friend he was there for me as
usual
and uh i've changed my life god gave me
a chance to change my life i'm in church
a lot man i pray a lot
i'm singing in the choir i'm playing
music
you know it's a big change in my life
you know so
hey man i love the lord and i'm gonna
stay with the lord i'm gonna go to
church every sunday
i got grandchildren i got great
grandchildren in church
so i'm marching with my grandbabies so
some people listening to this would have
a hard time reconciling the fact that
you're a religious
of a religious man and yet you're again
like i said i was the preacher's son
the preacher kids was the baddest kids
in the neighborhood breaking people
winners out their cars fighting all the
time
starting a lot of mess hey man i'm a way
better young man than i used to be
you know everybody wanted to be in the
game everybody want to be a gang
everybody want to be fight everybody
wanted a cadillac every
man i know right now want a pretty
cadillac and want a woman
to put some gas in his car and buy him a
suit so
that's nothing new to the community in
the neighborhood because
everybody want their car no paid not
just only
the men the women's want their house no
paid
they get you they give you a piece of
that potato pie they want their house no
pay they want they caught no pain they
want their nails did they want their
hair dead
so for the lawyers the doctors the
police officers the judges
have been supporting the players and the
pimps
welcome to the club cause if it weren't
for y'all
we couldn't have been looking as good
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
in all years man the most important
lesson i learned
if you got a family if you got
grandbabies you got a wife you got
children
respect your home whatever you do out in
that street
don't take it home leave it in the
street cause your grandbaby your son
your daughters is watching you
the best thing i can tell you to do get
in the lord house
i'm in church man
out of 30 years of god have changed my
life
i've been a great
better father for my children
and i can say hey man i've been out here
with some of the greatest brothers
i used to see some of the greatest
gamblers have shopping bags of money
i see them today they only have shoes on
their feet
so hey man i can say i thank god for
changing my life and giving me a chance
to get myself together i just want to
say that the ones that's out there
try to show love in your house where the
rapist has come from the girls getting
raped your nieces and nephew
it come from somebody out of your
household
your mama brother sister uncle of
somebody
to mess with that baby so question them
babies and
actually see if anybody been downstairs
tampering with them
and tell them that you love your babies
when you tell them that you
love them and spend time with them
and don't bring anybody around your
house
you're gonna hit jackpot if you know
what i mean by jackpot
but respect your house that's what i
learned
my daddy told me he said man i wish
i would have stayed home with your mama
and i used to hear him say that all the
time if your family you and your wife is
not getting along
you go in one room she go another room
learn how to shut the hell up i'm
talking to the men's today
learn to be quiet learn how to take some
mess
because a woman all she got for you is
she can cook for you good
wash your clothes and spray it eager for
you
cross the bed that's what she got for
you and when she spread eagle for you
good
that's like heaven it must be heaven so
if you
haven't not learned anything i have said
today
you are lost i'm gonna respect
first then she must respect you
you the man of the house you the king
of your house you are the man in the
street any pimple player you are the
king
but you got to respect your products you
can't dog your products that you're not
going to get none
back you grow
beautiful grass you're gonna get
beautiful grass so
that's what i learned respect
would take you a long ways do not let
the little head
make a fool out of the big head respect
your home that's number one do not bring
all your friends over your house
number two respect your mother and
father
if you don't respect your mother and
father you're not gonna respect your
sisters and brothers
and then if you don't respect home
you're not gonna respect
the street and then they're gonna kill
you you're gonna respect the streets the
streets got something for you
street got something for you the devil
got something for you you keep knocking
on the devil though
he got something for you stop knocking
on the devil though
go find you a job
when i was coming up i used to knock all
my neighbors though to take they gabba
job
i used to shelve where they snow
i used to clean up their backyard
i used to go in the grocery stores and
help
everybody who need groceries taken to
their car
i would do that there's always way in
making money
you ain't got the rob you ain't got the
steal
you ain't got the lie you can win like i
won
i won because i played the game fair
respect don't steal from your best
friend don't steal from your best friend
that's the point today you killed your
best friend in school went to school
with you killed them
you shot them in the back because it was
getting more money than you was getting
the drug dealers
i'm speaking on that but
it pays to do right today if you don't
have to go outside don't go outside
go look for a job if somebody got work
for you
but remember what i said again respect
will go a long ways for you
the same thing will make you laugh going
to make you cry
what do you think the biggest problem is
in the uh the poorer communities the
inner city
we're in the poke community today like i
said uh even child abuse
it's child abuse and no respect in the
home
that's why the young peoples are doing
what they doing today
because the mothers and fathers ain't
got time to train them the mother and
father
majored them in jail but grandmama can
only do what she have to do
she can only do so much these kids so
bad now man
they're taking pills the audi home is
fuller than the penitentiaries now
the audi homes it's kids killing their
mothers and fathers
they're killing their grandmamas there's
one kid from the west side where i come
from
the mama told him if some
whisper ever happened to me i got a half
a million dollar policy for you
what did she tell that kid for that
he set his mom off and got a kill and
collect the money not he in jail
so stop telling your children so much
right now
put the prayer back in your house put
the bible back on your table
sit down and talk to your kids whooping
them ain't gonna help
you got the mothers and fathers gotta
spend more time with their children now
when you don't want to spend time
do not bring different means around your
children i don't care what you do
don't bring them in your house do not
bring different spirits in your house
and i learned that man i thank god for
changing my life
if god can save me he can save you
if you can walk in the church and say i
want to change my life
god will change your life it's what you
want to do with yourself
you ain't got to be out here selling
your body
laying down with this man laying down
with this this woman
laying down with this woman today laying
down with that man you ain't got to do
that
that's no good that was that was a pole
thing that happened to me when i was a
kid with the babysitter used to take me
and my brothers and take us in the room
when you grow older just think of you
think about it you think about it you
think about it just do something to the
children
so pay attention to your children if you
ain't got a lot of money
keep them clean
keep them clean comb their hair go to
the thrift store and find them some
shoes they got some cheap shoes in there
but watch them and keep your kids clean
comb their hair
keep them in clean clothes and you'll
feel good inside and someone will see
you doing right
and someone give that person a chance
but you out there acting the food
it's no good say no to drugs from pills
don't let no man get you no pills
don't let nobody give you no alcohol
don't let nobody give you nothing
if you're doing wrong stop talk yourself
and say
i'm not going back out there no more i'm
not gonna do it i don't care if i don't
have a meal today
if you go over some of your friends that
you say don't like you knock on their
door say listen
i've changed my life whatever leftovers
y'all have at home for me and the kids
please call us i'll come and get them
we're looking for help right now
if you act with your pride you got too
much pride you don't want to help
you don't even want to ask somebody for
the help you
that's what we need today you got to
open up
and ask for help today if you ask for
help you're going to see what you're
going to get
because somebody's going to help you if
you say man please
i'm hungry man my baby's win we ate
today
when you cook with you put up something
to the side i bet you they put something
to the side for you
cause the first thing gonna say she
that girl came by my house and she said
the kids when they was
us was hungry and i put them something
to the side and i feel good i'm gonna
help them tomorrow
respect but you got to get yourself
together
starting today not tomorrow
right now but you got to look up towards
heaven and call on the lord
almighty jesus christ he will help you
and learn to be quiet talking so much
with that dead
your pink tomato
will get you in a world of trouble learn
to
be quiet if you got a mother father
sisters and brother
call them and tell them you love them
they don't know about love because you
ain't never told them you love them
so now you tell them not because they
never told you so you pick up that phone
and call seven people's in your family
and say look i just want to say i love
you
do that every day it's gonna come
natural your children's gonna hear you
say that they'll know what love is
they don't know because you don't know
what it was squares not understand
because what you're talking about you're
talking about a lot of religion you're
talking about believing in the lord and
all this but
then you're also doing things that a lot
of people a lot of squares would say
well how could you do i'm going to tell
you something i was on the
i was i was on the site working with
nick cannon and i was i got to talk
about the lord they told me to leave
you know uh i was shooting a video some
of these people told me
at one time for that so i'm talking to
the squad peoples too
don't you know the girls in the church
the square girls don't you know when
they at home sometime at night
they put on their daughter skirts and
look in the mirror
they want to look like that too so
you got to watch the square girls too
they got it in them too
now and then
what make it so bad you girls
you girls don't even have time to
entertain your husband
so that's why that's why the men's run
away from home
because you can't certify your husband
study how to certify your husband but
what you do you get in the bed with them
old
holes in your drawers when you're
supposed to have bikini panties or some
on
uh no panties for your man your womens
don't know how to entertain your man
so that's why they run in the street all
the time but what i was trying to tell
them
i'm talking to the squares and the
street people
respect go a long ways
so if you respect yourself first
you ain't got to stoop down level
but call on the man upstairs that's
what's saving me i'm in church
i'm going to stay on my bending knees i
don't care what you got to say bad about
me
everybody done done some wrong in life
and got a dead skeleton still in a
closet
me i'm not a hundred percent
but i'm 65 percent of trying to do right
may god bless you and may god keep you
but don't forget to pray
get on your knees and pray god bless you
all right mr seymour thank you so much
okay
may god bless you do the right thing
and god will cover you
you